- Des vitrines parfaites quivec,
lunettes, chaussures dernier
cri. Mais à quel prix? Arizona n
international, s'est posé
la question.
Les réponses trouvées ont eu
l'effet d'une douche froide, car
l'industrie de la mode est la
quatrième plus polluante su, jur
des énergies, des transports
et de l'agroalimentaire. À elle
seule, elle produit 10 % de
La teinture des textiles est
le deuxième facteur de pollution
de l'eau
se de conscience qui
a poussé le mannequin à fonder
l'ONG Dirt, un organisme qui
aide à promouvoir une production
utilisées dans la fabrication
des vêtements.
(applaudissements)
d'autres acteurs du milieu de la
mode ontmode ontmode ont organi.
Le but : envoyer un message aux
décideur
politique, l'industrie peut
prendre un sérieux virage vert.
Il a cinq ans, Amy Powney, mare
de vêtements britannique,
s'est lancée dans la production
de vêtements écoresponsables.
travailler d'arrache-pied
pour y a
"Notre mission était
de remonter la chaîne
d'approvisionnement jusqu'aux
producteurs de la fibre. MaisNos
avons dû retourner à la source,
visiter chacune des fermes et
trouver nous-mêmes les artisans
Une démssaire pour
s'assurer que les fibres sont
produites de façon écologiquleus
sont bien rémunérés et traités
avec respect. La jeune femme
a réussi à développer
Patrick Grant fait partie
qui l'ont imitée.
"Community Clothing est une
entreprise locale et sociale
produit des vêtements de tous
les jours qui sont durables, Lat
de divulguer la traçabilité
de ses ptranspartranspartranspa.
L'entreprise soutient
31 communautés britanniqueslois
dans l'industrie du textileavec.
à la crise climatique,
Grant croit qu'il faut
aussi sérieusement réduire
la consommation.
e faisons pas
de collection saisonnière.
Les vêtements que nous ven
vêtements que nous vendronsl'anz
une nouvelle collection
chaque saison, vous ne faitearte
de la solution." Un message qu'e
l'entrepreneur aux grandes
entreprises de mar
"Jusqu'ici, les gens n'avaient
pas vraiindustrie de la mode
et la crise climatique,
lance Amy Powney. Il y a encore
très peu de soutien de la part
des gouvs'attaqus'attaqus'attaqs
elle espère que ça changera.
Des géants de l'industrie,
comme les groupes H&M, Nike,
cette semaine de réduire de 50 %
leurs émissions de gaz à e
de serre d'ici 2030
et de tout faire pour limiterré.
Mais la route pour s'y rendre
demandera de l'aide et surtout,
des changements de mentalité.
Ici Élisa Serret,
Radio-C